good morning Johnny it's Monday opps say
yesterday fantastic day I've had a great
day yesterday it was the 1st of May and
true to Jonathan Coulton song it was a
gorgeous day outside though I did not
have any alfresco fornication or did I
witness any thank goodness
other Nilan got breakfast down town I
rented some friends who were filming a
movie and I got to be in their movie we
went to see win-win the new Paul
Giamatti awesome really good movie a red
Clash of Kings in my back porch as
someone bin Laden was killed in a
precision military strike Katherine and
I played Mario Kart we usually we were
playing Mario Kart we would Katherine
had to go to the bathroom I pulled on my
phone to check Twitter by the time she
got back I had my laptop on my lap and I
was watching Obama's address with the
Mario Kart music in the background the
United States has conducted an operation
that killed Osama bin Laden the leader
of al Qaeda it was a surreal moment and
I'm not gonna live Katherine and i
high-five and then we raced in the 100cc
banana cup I was Donkey Kong she was
Yoshi and she was so there are all kinds
of interesting discussions that I'm sure
people will be having over the coming
days like for example is it okay to
high-five your wife over the death of
another human being but instead of that
discussion since you know this happened
like mere hours ago it seems a little
premature to talk about all the
implication let's just talk uh for one
moment about what we actually know
before we launch into the spin cycle
number one despite the fact that Jack
Bauer was a trending topic on Twitter
last night the death of Osama bin Laden
had nothing to do with rogue agents or
weird intelligence activities are
breaking international treaties or
torture which is a really notoriously
bad information gathering technique and
there weren't even any 24-hour deadlines
was a long thought-out months-long
process gathered information over a long
period of em they put all that
information together using some great
deductive minds and they they figured it
out number two CIA operatives and the
Navy SEALs involved in the action
attempted tickets AMA bin Laden alive
but we're not able to is unclear when
this will be made into a made-for-tv
movie but my guess is minimum six months
five people were killed in the attack
four of them were al-qaeda members one
of them was a woman who was used as a
human shield by one of those al Qaeda
members which is horrible I mean all
zahary remains the number-one guy at al
Qaeda and he's been sort of the chief
operations guy for a long time and he's
a jerk
according to what I've read and various
leaked documents from the CIA he doesn't
have the same charismatic following it
might be hard for him to keep the
loyalty that that Osama bin Laden was
kind of holding together at al-qaeda so
this could be a pretty good thing and
lastly Brock Obama ordered this assault
right before flying to Alabama to survey
the damage done by the tornados and
talked to the people there and then
during the attack itself he called the
President of Pakistan he was like hey
President of Pakistan just wanted you to
know we found bin Laden we're coming to
get him we're either gonna take him
captive or win a kill him and uh sorry
for not asking permission but yeah we're
just gonna do this and that is a phone
call that I cannot imagine Donald Trump
making so glad Barack Obama was in
charge just then that's just me though
apologize for not you know waxing poetic
as John probably would have about the
you know emotions of our country about
the morality of assassination as we
receive this cold serve dish as for how
I feel personally my emotions are in a
lot of different places right now so
let's just say this the fact that I know
that I should not be happy at the death
of another human being that doesn't
change fact that I am John I'll see you
on Wednesday
endscreen so are not a very
light-hearted video that but you know I
have to say one thing here in John's
last video lots of people asked a
question and then got 125 or so thumbs
up that question did and that question
was when is Hanks first album coming out
and two or three years ago people this
is my second album this is the shirt
that came out with it it comes with a
poster 17 songs on it and we also just
reprinted these shirts they were
originally in green another in black my
next album will hopefully be coming out
in the month after this one what is that
April May June in June that's all okay
bye